In 1789, encyclopedists Voltaire and Rousseau have undermined the sacred nature of the monarchy.
Great principles, which were soon to blaze forth in France, were not forthcoming too easily.
Oh, my kidneys. Oh, this will never do. Oh, slow down.
Liberty. For centuries now, to the French people, it meant privileges.
What a fuss was made if we took any away.
Equality. It was but a few years the Parliament of Paris rose up against equality as far as taxes were concerned.
An unacceptable system which led only to disorder.
fraternity. Each social strata had only contempt for the one beneath it less privileged than they. And so on down the line.
The worst off, the great majority.
This inn looks like a nice place to estimate.
These voyages are extremely fatigued.
I'm finished.
Oh dear.
You are not eating.
Thank you, go ahead.
You don't mind if I eat your portion?
Well, but, believable.
At last, my trunk. I'll be able to die now.
My wine?
As I'm the elect of the people, I do claim for us all.
First all, a bit of coffee.
That's right.
It's late.
But now, to bed.
Let's take our precautions.
That's it.
If some robbers are thinking of breaking in here, they'll be well received.
Good night.
Beasties, I'll get all of you.
Can I rearrange all this?
That's it?
Think it'll do like that?
Forgot.
My traveling companions.
And now, good night.
And now what is it?
Oh no, it's not possible, it's an army.
I've got a good idea.
Now then, how do you like that, eh?
A good bath never did anyone any harm.
He'll go right ahead.
Don't you like it?
It's for Paris, all aboard.
Passengers, the horses are ready.
Please, sir, we are leaving.
There's far too many people.
I think that we've got to squeeze in tighter a bit.
Watch out, please.
Hold it, eh?
Not so much.
Watch out pushing me.
I'm grabbing on where I can.
Louis XVI acknowledged his inability to deal with the rampant economic crisis.
Threatened with bankruptcy, he summoned the Estates General for the 5th of May 1789.
This was the first time in 175 years.
From all parts of France, the delegates came to the capital.
By the 12th, 1789, the king gathered his troops around Paris.
He had just dismissed Necker, and a grim rumor spread: "Patriots will be executed."
Paris rumped.
Believe me, a reckoning is near.
The king gathers his troops, you'll be another Saint Bartholomew of the Patriots of Paris.
To arms!
Oh, dear me, this looks bad.
Enough's the laugh, eh?
It's time that the people fought back!
Huh?
Some bread! Give us some bread!
Come on!
I'm afraid it can only get worse now.
Wait!
But yes, it's...
It's... I'm sure it's the place where our friends live.
Come on!
Let's hurry, where's the fire?
Tell me if you don't mind where your father could be?
Some kind of mission.
Oh, we know what kind of mission, probably to a cafe.
And I suppose they want to remake the world drinking.
Bravo for all you've been doing.
And you, Maestro, I'd like to know what good work you've been up to today.
Ah, well, Pirat, today is June the 20th, and we all met at the Jeu de Pomme,
because the Salon of the Estates General had been occupied by the soldiers of the king.
Evacuate the place!
Orders of the king!
We're all special requests of the people.
We shall not move unless we're possible.
Not leave, except by force of bayonets.
That's the answer given by Mirabeau to the king's forces.
And then we called ourselves the National Assembly.
And it was then we drew up our constitution.
And we won't pay taxes anymore that we haven't passed by vote.
and we are going to form a good militia.
Oh, pardon.
And then we'll get all our arms
at the invalid.
Or maybe at the Bastille.
Pierre?
Pierre, hey, where are you? Answer me.
Pierre!
Look at the Bastille. It's burning.
They're taking the Bastille without me.
Sister, follow me.
Yes, I saw. Very good.
And the very next day...
Hey, citizen, I'm gonna show you how to do it. Look!
Huh?
What are you trying to do?
Well, you see, we're trying to demolish... bang!
The people...
And if you like, you can buy some little reminder of the bloodshed.
Yeah, it locks up the dungeons for one penny, for four pennies, the cannonball, and for two pennies, I'll offer you a fine.
No!
And who hasn't bought his rosette?
To the town hall.
Unbelievable. Come on, climb on my shoulders.
Tell me, I'll let you see.
Yes.
Lafayette, the head of the National Guard, is putting a rosette on the king.
From that day on, they would be the colors of the French flag.
It was the night of the 4th of August when some were driven by fervor,
and others by the great fear of losing all they had to their names.
They were to give up all their hard-earned privileges.
Well, almost all.
As soon as they came down to earth again, they bargained.
A fine line had to be drawn between those rights that were suppressed and those to be bought back.
Oh, just give that woman the hand.
It would be the Declaration of the Rights of Man and Citizen.
Principles of 89 assured liberty for each person, of opinion, of speech, of the press, equality and taxation.
Justice was free of charge. The nation was sovereign.
And what about duties? Were there only rights for the citizen?
To wipe up the brats. To stand in for prayer, the bakers.
Give us, we will demolition of the rights of women.
This is flour, and with this, we're bringing back flour until the baker's mayor, the baker's wife, and the biswick.
This is returning to my capital to receive all the signs of your respect and the love and the fidelity of its inhabitants.
And I sign Louis XVI King of Frenchman.
So, was that the end of the revolution?
Yes, the revolution could have ended there.
Gains were considerable.
The king, out of tune with the times, preferred to run off.
The 20th of June, 1791, recognized at Varenne he was forced to return.
The year is over, let the nation be restored to its happy state.
The king also swears to apply the constitution, as he swore to do one year before that.
But something was still wrong.
The king had too often played with the feelings of the nation.
Try it, son.
You're out of your house.
Oh, oh, oh, oh. Better I think too. How do you stop this thing? But from everywhere come rumors of war. Ask our country France to rise to lightning. We ask thousands of our citizens to come to the front lines. Citizens so do. That is liberty, understand me. And in whom do you put your trust to lead the war? In those who want your ruin, I suppose. Citizen Robespierre, Francis, driving to win all.
December of that year, obscured in all that misery, unnoticed by all, a great artist, Mozart.
Excellent dining, my friends.
It was a bit cool, wasn't it, my son?
Yes, I now present my latest invention.
And what's his...
I'll show you. Not perfected just yet.
April 1792. Once again, those who see war as the solution of all that is wrong have won.
Louis XVI encouraged them because he hopes that in their time of need, he will fall in his arms.
With the enemy nearing the capital, he thinks it is the clever thing to veto the creation of a militia of 20,000 men to defend the city.
Anger mounts.
Go on.
I'm treacherous, monsieur. You have deceived us. You continue to do so, but be careful. We've had enough.
And the people are tired to be played with like this.
All your affection is for the immigrants, not for the people.
That's not true. I love the people and the constitution.
The country had been declared in danger. The army marches on the capital.
Among them were the Marseillais, with their new anthem.
The monarchy is voted out, but the Prussians are near, and the Duke of Brunswick, encouraged by Louis XVI, announces a terrifying declaration.
The enraged mob returns to the Tuileries. This time, there was to be bloodshed, followed by the September Massacre.
Then, the unhoped for. The National Guard blocks the Prussians, and it's the victory of all...
Let us dance! Let us dance!
Goethe, a witness of these events, said,
Gentlemen, a whole new era in the history of mankind begins here, and it can be said, I was there.
Citizens, citizens, believe me.
It is the truth I speak.
There's only one choice.
It is that of virtue, that's all.
Oh, no, there's only one choice.
It's that of reason for me.
That's the only two days.
And the debate was started, uncompromising virtue or reason.
The convention, elected this time by unanimous vote, assembled the day after Volmi.
The 21st of September, monarchy was abolished.
The republic declared the 22nd.
1792, the French troops defeat the Prussians and the Austrians.
1893 the victorious convention takes care of the king judge him we're obliged to oppose him he's opposed the people and been vanquished i ask for his death
louis the sixties must perish for our great nation to live his death
it was a split 360 votes for his death 360 votes against it then it was philip of orleans turn to vote
convinced that all those who have attacked the sovereignty of the people deserve to die i vote for his death
And it was with that one vote, his cousins, the Duke of Orleans, that Louis XVI was condemned to death.
And us with the death of your son, who filled us with hope in what we believe,
make us attain and accomplish our desires by the resurrection of your own son,
who is the Lord, lives and reigns with you in the unity of the Holy Spirit over all time.
And so be it.
We have been doing our work well, citizens.
We must continue, but now the situation is clear.
The bridges are cut, and are we able to...
Only heads are cut, and you'll get the foreign countries on your back.
Anarchy to trouble makers, the ambitious, and even yes, I might add, and even not the least of your problems, you'll get the road spirit.
You're nothing but a defeatist, citizen.
Oh yeah, citizen, we'll see who...
The nation is divided. The enemy is at the borders. The convention toughens up.
We would need 100 heads to save our revolution, and I propose that...
Give that man a nice glass of blood to refresh him.
Probably very urgent. Looks like a plot.
You wanted some dames, huh?
Butties.
The convention, in a dangerous position, decreed the revolt of the masses.
It was soon to be the end of organized warfare fought by professional armies.
The whole nation was at war.
First of the great massacres, a nation against itself was launched.
Some trousers for budgers.
Well, here's another bag.
Come on, citizens, give us your shoes for the soldiers of the republic.
Recuperate drones for making cannons.
Simuliac.
Pierre has replaced Danton on the Committee of Public Welfare.
Reign of Terror is near.
well sir my boy i think i've got it perfected finally can regenerate only on mountains of
cadavers it's a crime against the republic not to want the reign of terror yes terror is an offshoot
of virtue oh be quiet citizen rob sphere in face of your rotten politics you would be right to jump
into the lake i want that woman expand a woman can rise to the guillotine and so she can also rise up
in the tribunal and so she did freedom you revenge my death and the reign of terror continued
Monotonously.
Liberty, what crimes we commit in your name.
Can't you slow down, Mr. Executioner?
What's the big hurry?
God, he's ugly.
Quiet, it's not the right time to criticize me.
I won't be much longer.
You know what really bothers me?
That my death is six weeks before Robespierre's.
And now I've got it perfectly right.
Oh.
Danton was not mistaken.
The terrible law of Prairielle, the ninth month,
was to turn everyone against Robespierre.
D'Italien, you have a very last chance.
You know that our days are our number.
Teresa, I will save you.
I bid you seize Robespierre and arrest him on the spot.
He has undermined the revolt.
Go on.
Now hold it.
The Tenth of Thermidor.
Bet you I'll be replacing that man.
At least I wasn't talking about that one there.
The fall from power of Robespierre and his friends marked the end of the reign of terror.
A new dance was the rage of Paris, the waltz.
More than 600 balls were given that year, each one attended by marvelous and incredible women.
Divorce had just been legalized, and it too was all the rage.
Oh, I'm a darling.
Theresa, here I'd like you to meet my latest husband, the citizen le tenueuse, my good friend Theresa.
Congratulations, you both know Barav.
Monsieur, I'm sorry to disturb you.
A messenger has just arrived and he insists that it's very serious.
It was just announced to Barav that there was a royalist insurrection.
Since the little Bonaparte was not on active duty anyway and relaxing in the salon.
We are sure to trust you in this urgent business and try to show yourself worthy.
So with 40 well-placed cannons, the young Bonaparte crushed the final hopes of the royalists.
But Paris knew only misery and hunger. Inflation soared.
A pity on a poor rich man, dear madame. Thank you.
Introducing my very last husband, the Citizen Abou.
The bread ration fell as low as 60 grams a day.
Possible. It wasn't worth the trouble to have the ration to end where we are.
Grab all the bread. Come on. Let people out.
Yes, what the directory needed was a clear-minded man.
A strong one to straighten things out.
A man sent by Providence.
But let us return to Madame Tallien's salon.
Happiness with her husband didn't last long and she was much taken with Bonaparte,
but she tired soon enough of a little general with no future,
who at any rate was more interested in the ravishing Josephine, who Barra was now tired of.
Bonaparte falls madly in love, wants to marry her, but he's penniless.
Josephine didn't exactly say no and would be interested if her general had a little position.
Barra, head of the army, makes a gesture.
He gives Bonaparte the little army in Italy.
Whatever the outcome, nobody expected much from him, but much was to happen indeed.
Yes, France was greatly involved.
The European nations didn't get along for a century.
Long before the collective suicide of 1914, from which two giants emerged, Napoleon was
to say, as I die, I leave two giants yet in their cradles to revenge me, Russia and the
United States of America.